what's about the SNL days because people
love to hear about those times we're
we're gonna we're gonna time travel now
back to the year 1951. and you and I
worked on a radio show called Saturday
Night Live so uh you you mentioned Tom
and so Frank and Davis we would do this
show within the show called The Franklin
Davis show and we had my parents on uh
twice and once they got cut
your parents got cut between dress and
air it's rough and so the first time
they're on they just came on and I the
character I played was me as an
right and so uh
wait that was a character that was that
was a character it's just like you
self-deprecate and paint yourself kind
of as an all the time yeah we
all know and we all know complete
opposite exactly 180 degree so that was
the whole premise here kind of so anyway
so I have my parents on and
um I sing a song to them hey Mom and Dad
this song is for you everything I sing
it a different key better anyway so
um and I think and then my mom says this
reminds me of when they called from
school and said you'd your pants or
something like that Mommy am I gonna get
mad at her and my dad says stop yelling
at your mother and she's like crap your
pants this is right right and then I get
mad at him I'm an and I didn't I
kick my dad in the ass okay so that one
was on everyone loved it
next time I have mine Tom and I would do
very dark stuff and in this one I think
um
I have them they're in dress they're uh
they're they're wearing uh stars of
David
and overcoats Circa 1930
five
Nazi Germany
and Tom and I are in gestapo outfits
right
look at the smile on your face wow this
was Art
this was something you kind of could do
back then right you could do very dark
the the show Hallmark of the show it's
sometimes very dark especially after a
certain hour things could get very yeah
and Tom and I were always on after that
hour right and so the whole point was at
a certain point my dad goes Alan I I
can't do this
I decide
we rehearsed it and you know we've done
it all week why do you say now we're on
the show we're live I just can't and my
friends I I can't go back to Temple
and do this sketch with you in the
Gestapo you know and then I get really
mad at him and yell at them and this
kind of ends that way yeah Bernie
berlstein famous uh what would you call
him manager no he was a manager but he
was even beyond that he's a man that
looked like Santa Claus and was a show
business Legend and had a big
Personality yeah he was a and uh
represented everybody including Lauren
and just said to him he's watching a
dress and going you can't do this
so and I guess he was right and so I
think we could have done it but uh but
anyway so uh we get my parents get cut
and Lauren comes after up to me after
the show
I said out don't put me in the position
of cutting your parents ever again
were they upset that they were cut they
must have been a little bit but I mean
they understood
I couldn't go like Lauren that's amazing
you cut us on the Gestapo Star of David
my parents as that's just the Tiffany
Iceberg with you you were constantly
pitching ideas that you loved to go
right up to the edge and sometimes over
it oh oh yes Miles and Miles Beyond were
you always like that well I think I just
came of age during a period where
very dark humor was about
the opposite of it in other words that
you were exploring
really dark things in order to laugh at
how awful they were that's all yeah yeah
I went over a line at times and were you
on the show at Comic Killers okay so
this was Downy and I had this idea for
Jim Downey yeah head writer yeah uh for
uh it was a game show like Jeopardy but
it was called comedy Killers so the the
categories were
uh the Holocaust the Kennedys uh cancer
yeah and so this is a joke I tell in my
act because
everything I'd ever done
when I ran for the senate in comedy it
was used against me yeah
and I told the joke from that sketch
that Rosie Schuster wrote and it was
this would have been a bad gift for Anne
Frank right what is a drum set
oh oh God Jesus
so that's brought up now of course
you're running then for Senate
and uh how Franken told jokes about the
Holocaust yeah yeah
so I'd written a uh magazine article in
the late 90s saying that parents should
probably
um monitor what their kids get online
and uh so but I wrote it satirically so
I said my son Joe did a great fourth
grade report last week on bestiality and
he downloaded a lot of great visual aids
and the kids in the class just love them
and it was Al Franken
dope jokes about beastiality
so we had to Chuck Schumer
was like monitoring my race I was
running for the nomination at the time
yeah and he's going this is too much
baggage and
[Applause]
so my pulse we had to do focus groups to
see if this really was a problem and if
we could
you know overcome it and so she had the
focus group in and she the first
question she asked if you knew that Al
Franken told jokes about bestiality
would you be more likely to vote for him
okay
it turned out less likely
but we discovered that
you know if you explain things that
minnesotans got irony
and they got you know what satire was
and so it wasn't a real problem and then
I went out
to show this great report saying it
wasn't a problem to Harry Reid and then
he asked me what joke could you tell
about the Holocaust
[Laughter]
[Music]
I said well it uh okay the joke was I
think a bad Hanukkah gift for Anne Frank
would have been a drum set and then
Harry started shaking
and I start thinking okay this is either
very good or very bad right and he just
thought it was the funniest joke you'd
ever
[Laughter]
so I was okay right after that oh I but
the best joke in comedy Killers the
sketch you remember was Final uh comedy
killer like Final Jeopardy uh last it
was you know the ding ding ding ding
ding the long uh was uh the biggest
comedy killer of all time
Danny wrote this joke here it was what
was the assassination of Archduke
Ferdinand
how did this sketch play in front of the
audience great did it yeah
it was what year was it I don't know it
was in the 80s I think that's probably I
think world war one was closer at that
time yeah people have forgotten it was
like you know 34 years closer or
something 35 years closer so everyone
was a big
you know oh that was terrible or and of
course started by the assassination of
Archduke Ferdinand Yeah by Gabriel
princip I think shot him yes
interesting
Archduke Ferdinand was on his way back
he was he was leaving uh Sarajevo are
you doing a comedy killer yeah okay he's
leaving Sarajevo his driver took a wrong
turn really and his car kind of stopped
right in front of a cafe
Principe had his chance to shoot uh you
know the Archduke and hadn't done it but
the the suddenly he's sitting in a cafe
consoling himself by having a cup of
coffee when this car pulls up in front
of that cafe
and who's in it but the Archduke and his
wife and he just puts his cup of coffee
down and steps out and kills them both
what an insane coinky dink
anywho we were doing comedy killers and
I wanted to keep going
well that that shows
something no nothing what what I'm sorry
why do you suddenly have the balls to do
it if he was if he couldn't do it the
first I think he wasn't able I think he
didn't have a shot yeah he just couldn't
do it not said he like chickened out I
think his blood sugar was low but then
he had a donut and a cup of coffee and
then uh this guy in a big hat with
ostrich feathers and medals pulls up
right outside he read his horoscope too
and it was in favor of it yeah yeah yeah
yeah and the waiter said oh we're also
serving gun today
I grabbed a gun and said I'll take one
of those and then the whole thing just
came together beautifully okay yeah